[Music]
hello everyone I'm Pete also known as
snow though here to give you guys a
review for mutant Year Zero road to Eden
so I played it for about two hours two
and a half hours and I found the game to
be very enjoyable now for people that
don't know this game is set in the
future after and spoilers I should say
that first after an apocalypse has
occurred in the world and people who are
these mutants are trying to survive and
in doing that they have to scavenge
materials and just like everyone is seen
in The Walking Dead there is huge
conflicts that occur between monsters
and creatures of certain sorts that
aren't normally seen now you take the
role of two characters who are who are
looking to go and find these resources
for their elder now you are a mutant
duck and boar and you end up finding
other people on your journey as you
started as you start in the first hour
they give you pretty much a tutorial to
teach you how to move throughout the
world what you're searching for and they
finally getting you to that first town
where the elder gives you your mission
to find this individual called Hammond
now I wanted to just state a couple of
things I've heard a lot of great things
about this game from when it was
starting and I really really wanted to
get my hands on it do a little review
really see how the gameplay was I'm a
huge XCOM fan and I love the combat and
it for XCOM and I wanted to see how it
was going to translate here
now it translated way better than I
thought I could because an ex-con
you're taking you're dropped in a zone
your ends up fighting
you end up trying to survive through
that mission missions complete you're on
you're done with routes eaten you end up
having to go from scenario to scenario
fluidly so you don't have those brakes
like you did in XCOM now what really
makes it interesting is that you are
going through a map just like you do any
RPG or JRPG and you get to the point
where you start seeing people walking
across the map now at that time you have
to make a decision if you are going to
skulk fully go around them or are you
going to fight them if you're gonna plan
on fighting you can ambush them so you
end up placing your people into position
you end up then attacking them before
they can attack you and if you use some
weapons and you kill them the others
won't come if you use weapon and others
are gonna hear your get more people
coming to fight them so it's gonna be a
lot more mobs if it's gonna be a lot
more difficult for you to play now I
played the game on hard because I played
very lots of different realtime strategy
type games because like I said I I
played XCOM 2 5 6 times through now the
it was way harder than I thought it was
going to be and it has taken me a long
time to start to kind of get my my feet
wet on it and I want to continue to play
this and beat it now I want to say that
the graphics on it or they're pretty
good they're you know they're not
they're not like 10 out of 10 they're
not like super great but they really
really do hold their own now the
graphical artists they did a fantastic
job with with the duck and the boar and
the environments are
very fluid and very enjoyable to play
with your weapons you you get a lot of
different variables and you can end up
putting different types of items on
there for instance the duck has a across
well you can end up putting on different
attachments to get an increase range use
damage or flame buff on it so you have
all these different elements that you
can add to make it specifically yourself
and then while you're going through your
level of process you end up getting
mutations on your character so if you
end up going through at a certain time
you can end up ducking end up having
wings so and he can end up giving better
shots and things like that where the
boar can end up doing taunts so I've
only gotten to the point where I've
ended up getting one other character so
you have boar you have duck and then you
have this this female character that I
ended up picking up
Selina I think her name was and it's
really it's really good now now I've
gotten to the point where I don't know
where I have to go next because I feel
like I need to take a step back and
level my characters get some gear and
then go forward so I have to I have to
figure out where I'm gonna be done with
that but I think I think it's a great
game and it's and I love the complexity
of it because I love hard games to do
especially these types of games and that
was the other thing when I was gonna
start that the the game there actually
is an option for almost like an Ironman
mode I don't know about you but that
just scares the bejesus out of me that
you're allowed to do that because if you
lose your character you're not getting
them back so but I let's say thank you
very much I would definitely recommend
this game to others if you do not know
this it is in the Xbox game pass and it
is also in I think that's going to be in
steam and I'm not sure about the
PlayStation but thank you all very much
for listening to the review thank you
for hanging out thank you for coming to
see the iron Lords
as you guys know we are on Sundays at 11
o'clock and I think two more weeks from
now which is end of December we will be
moving back to one each turn so thank
you again everyone and have a fantastic
night continue watching some gameplay
and enjoy
have a good one
state that was awesome
run-and-gun firmly just help that one
point
true enemy attention to your soul
fire tears only when I hate
mr.
so
enhance privileges to pop the hood
so
fly your eye
Trevor's want to talk let's brass
[Applause]
that's the closest to a map we have
what's that because our Fox found 112
notes found zero of 25 well hold up two
ghouls hiding over there I think they
want to hit you ride on her elevator
forget that let's sneak around and see
if there's any others
there's the tools in Sammy
and this is nice because you actually
have to use this meeting
just quickly how do you put that that
was fun but you need the range the
crossbow and Stan should you have other
weapons too
another one bites the ducks see the
artifacts extend crudely about time
Becky turns all Knox and extra grenades
slap her a member grants a 20% discount
in the shot it's fire damage to molotovs
improves medkits better increases
Canadian critical of those mechanical
impurities damage
it's probably is gonna be best you know
the drill
stalkers want gear that keeps them alive
I
Aradia provide the gear see anything you
like just let me know there is one rule
don't ever ever pull my chain if you
pull my chain I'll feed your ding-dongs
to its own rules got that beautiful
happy shopping
see
smoke grenade long table and grenade
by interesting good to know my home will
always be a haven to you brave stalkers
after your journeys pay me a visit
man and I offer you some guidance
these were HAP's a story to help you
become wise and strong
[Music]
farewell hmm
remember your elders guidance
I don't know how this goes down for the
right price I fix it upgrade your shitty
gear any questions
[Music]
so let's take a look here
you would scopes damaged mouths
[Music]
it's too damaged arrange ETSU I'm sorry
plus one additional critical damage and
a 50% chance of burn enemies
[Music]
grades take over damage so scopes and
stuff that's the matter just recover not
back
later stalkers so upgrade your weapons
free it is be a lot more than else it's
not silent
safe travels
let me guess that's not goals which
takes everything but are no secrets
where are the secrets
so in first
over watch
[Applause]
I'm a hundred percent shot from there
he's got some adjusting twenties the
shooting in it to do purple damage but
lowers the chance to hit
let's reduce any factors
she has no idea what happened because
silence would he run out the back the
front door
go Andy ignited
I'm sorry what what
running gun now we have two guys
over watch
so we know those guys are going to
closer to us
overwatch the problem is that shaman is
going to shoot
your buddy let me help you okay
I'm the death-dealing soul-stealing
stalking machine baby
[Music]
there you go this is really crazy
thank you
no matter what at 75% because he is on
the other side of that wall
so the only way to do is to see if you
can
move around people and use their covers
to their disadvantages
oh man that was my shot
[Music]
or watch
unlike the bullet on so you can kind of
see where they're going things
[Music]
my god
[Music]